knowing that gossipy do you feel sorry
for ginny weasley throughout the Harry
Potter series there are plenty of
reasons why we think you should feel bad
for this witch that doesn't get the
praise she deserves from her family
dynamics Tara time at school and of
course let's not forget her love life
Ginny had it tough join us as we unpack
why Ginny isn't as popular as she
deserves to be get to know the youngest
Weasley's hardship and all the moments
when we felt sorry for her being the
only girl in a family with six brothers
has got to be a struggle and being the
youngest - that's like a double hurdle
for Ginny both of those factors meant
that Ginny often missed out on things
and was forgotten even by the time Ginny
was in the fourth year at Hogwarts
her mother was still treating her
differently - her brother's due to her
age Ginny was the only one that her
mother banished from the meeting when
Sirius filled in Harry and the others
about the order of the Phoenix's work
and bull de mort wants to build up his
army again 14 years ago he had huge
numbers of his command and not just
witches anyone with a big family can
relate to this experience of getting
lost amongst the siblings and anyone
who's the youngest child can surely
empathize with Ginny about being told
you're not old enough all the time
growing up at the Burrow looks like a
lot of fun even though the family
struggled financially but it's not quite
so much fun if you don't get to do all
the things that your siblings do while
most of her brothers played Quidditch in
the garden
Ginny wasn't allowed to join in we
discovered that she was so desperate to
take part that she started breaking into
the family broom shed when she was just
six years old she would take each of
their brooms out in turn and here's our
first indication of how underrated Ginny
skills truly are we think of Fred and
George as the masters at keeping secrets
but Ginny was never caught taking their
brooms it wasn't until Hermione revealed
the secret to Fred and George eight
years later that it came to light of
course Ginny went on to be a very
successful Quidditch player she played
for the Gryffindor team at school and
also proved her leadership skills when
holding tryouts with Harry in the
half-blood Prince
while harry struggled to get them all to
be quiet Ginny commanded
tension with a simple she also made a
professional career out of the sport as
an adult after playing for the Holyhead
harpies she became the senior Quidditch
correspondent for the Daily Prophet
impressive stuff but back to the Weasley
family dynamic with big personalities
like Fred and George
it's no wonder Ginny didn't get much
attention she also wasn't a troublemaker
so she faded into the background a lot
of the time we can see how she gets
dismissed when she's desperate to go
with Ron when he starts at Hogwarts when
the ten-year-old begs her mom to join
him Molly Weasley replies you're not old
enough Ginny now be quiet
Ginny had to watch each one of her big
brothers head off to Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry fest while she
was left at home it would have been hard
enough watching Bill Charlie Percy Fred
and George head off on their adventures
but a hardest of all would have been
when Ron went she was left at home with
her parents for that year without any
siblings for company in the first book
she was so sad that she began to cry as
the Hogwarts Express pulled out running
along the platform after the train but
little did Ginny know that when she did
eventually make it to Hogwarts she
wouldn't have the best first year to say
Ginny had a traumatic first year at
Hogwarts would be an understatement
Ginny would have wanted to carve out her
own identity at Hogwarts rather than
just being known as the Weasley boy's
little sister but she wouldn't have
wanted to make a name for herself for
all the wrong reasons like she did in
the Chamber of Secrets the young and
impressionable Ginny was manipulated
into doing awful things because of Tom
Riddle's diary the book used her as a
vessel for evil making her open the
Chamber of Secrets and released the
basilisk to petrify Argus Filch's cat
mrs. Norris cat and write threatening
messages on the wall like the Chamber of
Secrets has been opened enemies of the
heir beware and it made her opened the
Chamber of Secrets again and again with
Colin Creevey
Justin Finch fletchie Hermione Granger
and Penelope Clearwater all being
petrified as a result
this is why money was in the library the
day she was attacked she worried she was
losing her mind she had gaps in her
memory and then the diary tried to end
her life of course Harry saved Jenny and
life went on it was me by sweat I didn't
mean to it'll make me but there are
clues in later books that Ginny was left
traumatized by the experience in the
Prisoner of Azkaban she had a severe
reaction to the Dementors on the
Hogwarts Express because of her
traumatic experience with the diary Ron
described her as shaking like mad
remaining had to comfort the sobbing
pale Ginny and in the half-blood Prince
Ginny tells Harry off for being careless
with the mysterious book in the movie we
see her take Carrie to the Room of
Requirement to hide the half-blood
Prince's book so that he can't find it
again it sounds like she held on to the
trauma of that experience for years
afterwards see you never know what
you'll find out there in fact in the
order of the Phoenix book Ginny admits
to Harry that she'd never truly gotten
over her experience of being possessed
by Tom Riddle she spoke with him about
it after Harry had convinced himself
that he'd been possessed by bull de mort
and attacked Arthur Weasley we discover
many of Ginny's concerns when she writes
in Tom Riddle's diary she confides about
how her brothers teased her how she felt
about having secondhand robes and bugs
and how she worried Harry would never
like her the one thing jenny has
received most hate about is her
relationship with Harry many fans don't
think they belong together shipping
Harry and Hermione instead or Harry and
Cho or Harry and anyone other than Ron's
little sister and Ginny's love for Harry
has caused her plenty of embarrassment
and pain over the years
Ginny loved Harry from such a young age
we can see this right away in the
philosopher's stone book when she's keen
to get a glimpse of Harry at platform 9
and 3/4 in the movie Ginny gets to wish
Harry
Gazi runs through the wall at the
station for the first time near the
beginning of the Chamber of Secrets
Danny finds Harry in the Weasleys
kitchen goes bright red and runs off we
definitely feel for Jenny in that moment
Jenny started out so shy around Harry
having a big crush on your big brother's
best friend is a pretty embarrassing
situation to be in the ends of the books
we'll know that Jenny sent Harry a truly
embarrassing singing Valentine during
her first year at Hogwarts it wasn't in
the movie but in the Chamber of Secrets
we read about Ginny writing up home for
Harry and telling it to a dwarf to pass
on to her crush it was meant to be
anonymous but Draco Malfoy's blew her
cover these are the kinds of moments
that we wish had been shown in the
movies a girlfriend in the Prisoner of
Azkaban book Ginny again has an
embarrassing moment involving Harry in a
card when Harry Falls from his
broomstick in a Quidditch match during a
storm
Ginny gives him a get well soon card
when she visits him in the hospital wing
the singing card makes Ginny blushed
furiously these differences between the
books and the movies also point to why
Jenny doesn't necessarily have the
biggest fan following from the film's
Bonnie right hardly gets any screen time
as Ginny across the franchise of movies
but in the books JK Rowling gives us
lots of reasons to love Ginny in the
book it's feisty Ginny who gives readers
valuable lessons about being yourself
and owning your accomplishments but in
the movies she's more of a Wallflower
and doesn't have a huge amount of
chemistry with Harry by the time we get
to the Goblet of Fire Ginny starts to
take control of her nerves around Harry
Hermione advises her to relax when she's
with Harry and to go out with other boys
in the meantime so Jenny gets on with
her life and goes to the Yule Ball with
Neville Longbottom and she starts dating
Michael corner - by the order of the
Phoenix Ginny has become much more
relaxed around Harry when she helped the
Gryffindor team beat ravenclaw in her
second Quidditch match by capturing the
Golden Snitch her boyfriend Michael gets
all Moody about the result he sulks over
Gryffindor winning the footage Cup
did Jenny put up with that childish
behavior oh no she didn't
Jenny drops Michael soon after because
of his attitude she's showing that your
partner should support your victories
not bring you down she goes on to date
Dean Thomas as well so you study which
expected to get up and leave much to
Fred and Georgia's delight they say to
her in front of the jealous Harry and
Harry certainly starts to take notice
Ginny has put up with Ron having a go at
her about kissing Dean in public she
sticks up for herself calling her
brother a hypocrite after he kisses
lavender Brown in public anyone with an
overprotective hypocritical brother can
surely feel a sense of solidarity with
Ginny over that we wish this girl power
side of Ginny could have come across
more in the movies although she
eventually got very close with Harry
becoming his girlfriend at school and
then his wife Ginny was always on the
outside of the trio's core friendship
and her own strengths were often
overlooked take for example how she was
left behind when Harry broke up with her
to go on the Horcrux hunt they'd been
dating for most of Harry's sexier but he
didn't think to take her with him Ginny
had proven how skilled and capable she
was as a witch and how loyal she was as
a girlfriend and friend so why couldn't
she help the trio Harry praised her for
her Patronus skills in a Dumbledore's
Army training session Jenny had plenty
of skill for defensive magic like the
disarming charm she also showed her
power with the red dr. curse that was
another talent that impressed Harry and
made her brothers jealous and her bat
bogey hex was so impressive that Horace
Slughorn invited her to join his slug
club while the trio of Harry Ron and
Hermione were off on their mission Ginny
was braving it out at Hogwarts in the
books we see how Ginny and Neville keep
Dumbledore's Army going at school but
it's Neville's heroics that made the
film Jenny definitely has strength as a
witch and that strength was underrated
theaters can hate but there was always a
connection between them even when they
were broken up like when they're getting
ready for bill and fleurs wedding and
here he does up Ginny's dress for her
before they kiss morning
let's not forget that Jenny had taken
the lead - kissing Harry in the Room of
Requirement yes she's a great role model
do you feel bad for Ginny - let us know
what you think of Ginny in the comments
and hit that subscribe button to know
when we release more videos on the
things thanks for watching
[Music]